gibt es ufos oder gibt es keine ist das
hier der ultimative beweis 32 jahre bei
dieser schnappschuss aus der
schottischen ortschaft calvin streng
geheim wir sehen ein seltsames
flugobjekt die chronische diamant form
etwa weiter abseits ein harrier kampfjet
der royal airforce aufgenommen von zwei
köchen in den schottischen highlands
eigentlich sollte dieses bild bis 20 76
in den geheimakten des britischen
verteidigungsministeriums vergraben
bleiben jetzt ist das bild aber an die
öffentlichkeit geraten rufe oder
spinnerei das ist die große frage und
das fragen wir unseren experten matthias
wieder schön dass du da bist verloren
vielen dank ja wieviel wertstoffen jetzt
diesen bild zuordnen naja sie ja schon
so wie du gesagt hast das bild sollte
tatsächlich geheim gehalten werden zu
verzögerten das damals in den britischen
heilands beim ausflug
fotografiert und wollten es eigentlich
an eine lokalzeitung gebend jetzt dann
aber tatsächlich an das
verteidigungsministerium weiter gegeben
und dort ist es in den geheimakten
gelandet und soll tatsächlich im büro
des damaligen chefs dieses ufo büros des
britischen verteidigungsministeriums als
riesiges poster im büro gehangen haben
und dieser liegt pro partnern
tatsächlich immer wieder auch gesagt
nachdem er seine funktion aufgegeben hat
das sei das spektakulärste foto was
jemals ihnen zugeschickt worden
und dann ist es so dass ein britischer
historiker sich auf die suche begeben
hat und einen ehemaligen presseoffizier
ausfindig gemacht hat der damals diese
fotos die hände bekommen hat und er hat
tatsächlich einen abzug behalten und so
ist er absolut sie in die öffentlichkeit
gelangt es ist ja nicht das erste mal
dass ein unheimliches oder geheimes
flugobjekt oder fotos oder bilder
schnappschüsse davon auftauchen diese
typische form ebenso nicht warum ist es
diesmal klarer als bei den anderen malen
na ja also ich glaube der hintergrund
ist oder ist wovon man ausgehen kann man
ausgehen ja ausgehen kann ist dass es
sich tatsächlich um ein echtes objekt
handelt was fotografiert worden ist und
was auch dass fotos auch untersucht
worden von experten einer universität in
der dieser historiker arbeitet also es
jetzt keine
keine fälschung oder keine kein gag den
sich über welche leute erlaubt haben und
außerdem ist es tatsächlich so dass
diese form immer wieder auftaucht bei
unbekannten flugobjekten die mir wieder
ein von menschen beobachtet werden also
diese diamanten reform ist eine immer
wiederkehrende form das gibt auch videos
davon aus kolumbien aus mexiko
und wie gesagt es spricht sehr viel
dafür dass das tatsächlich ein objekt
gewesen ist was die beiden männer
fotografiert haben wo sich offenbar
niemand erklären kann was dahinter
steckt wir müssen aber noch ganz einmal
ganz kurz klarstellen wir diskutieren
hier nicht über außerirdische bei aliens
ich würde sagen wir diskutieren auch
darüber also ufo heißt er immer
unbekanntes flugobjekt und das wird
schon seit jahrzehnten von regierungen
untersucht und taucht auch seit
jahrhunderten immer wieder in der
menschheitsgeschichte auf oder seit
jahrtausenden und niemand kann sich hat
erklären was dahinter steckt es gibt
jetzt im us senat gibt es große gab es
große anhörung es gibt untersuchungs
büros kommissionen in allen aller herren
ländern in den usa und frankreich in
südamerika die dieses phänomen
untersuchen was wirklich dahinter steckt
kann jemand sagen es gibt menschen die
sagen möglicherweise sind es außer oder
studiums besucht es gibt menschen sagen
das sind vielleicht besucher aus einer
anderen dimension vielleicht handelte
sich auch vielen fällen tatsächlich um
geheime militärtechnik die getestet wird
das weiß niemand aber fakt ist
scheinen zu existieren die wir in diesem
foto sehen
[Musik]